here's how it goes in the music
[ __ ]
i was a rapper before i was a wrestler
so you were rapping they found me they
found me i was a rapper talking [ __ ]
and um
triple h said to me when i got outside
do you want to be a rapper do you want
to be a wrestler i said i want to be a
wrestler you said i want to hear about
this rap [ __ ] again so i'm in the wwe
i'm under contract and i know that
everything i do is owned by them
so i meet spiff i get in the studio
i
get some of the best beats and grammy
award-winning producers libraries i have
beat libraries from spiff back in the
day that i hear on kanye albums that i
hear on travis scott albums wow and i
was just practicing over these beats
right right while you were wrestling
while i was wrestling so i was just in
the studio trying to get better
trying to work on this craft and you got
to be focused you got you got to treat
the same like if you want to be a rapper
eric
you got to go treat it the same way you
treated wrestling this is no [ __ ]
half-assed [ __ ] you gotta go full tilt
and i was just toying with the music
trying to get myself prepared for a life
outside of the wwe which i was well on
my way to i mean if you watched where i
was at you know i didn't plan on
resigning oh you didn't plan on sticking
around my body was [ __ ] broken i
never missed dates i got booked every
weekend you know how hard it is to get
booked every weekend for people who
don't realize like how many dates a year
is that because people don't understand
it's not just uh
smackdown and raw there's dark shows and
smaller markets that aren't on tv it's
probably about a hundred to two hundred
matches a year and you're wrestling
you're getting thrown away including all
the travel and all the other [ __ ] that
you're doing it's just a real crazy
lifestyle man it's insanity so it's not
sustainable there are the freaks that
get it done like who legends chris
jericho like what
yeah he's caught from a different club
or like you can't be broken well even
thinking like peak john cena like john
cena was everywhere still to this day
like he didn't he just the schedule i
just think about like 2010 john cena
that's how that's how dwayne johnson
flipped his [ __ ] man he took a
a [ __ ] note out of vince mcmahon's
playbook like hey bro first guy to show
up last guy to leave wake up at 4am
[ __ ] don't take no for an answer
it's like yeah there it is like work
harder than everyone it's just
harder than ever
vince would never ask you to do
something he wouldn't do
that's what i tell my people so that's
that's that's it right so you know
i i got it i i didn't i i looked at him
i admired vince the whole time i was
there i wanted to be that guy so it
seems like you i mean obviously but the
music this is where i'm at i'm going to
say the music
i had all this music i had been making
when i released that project that's
music from 2013 2014 that i'm releasing
in 2018.
that is not who i sound like now but
because i had invested this money own
these beats and had this shot
had to put it out didn't question it
are there records out there that i'm not
proud of no i'm proud of every one of
them because i had the balls to release
it and i didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
had to say
that's where you win don't give a [ __ ]
say what you want why don't you print
out those lyrics you don't like the way
i sound you don't like the way i rap
print out my lyrics
and you'll see that i am a [ __ ]
writer
same guy
i'm the same guy who wrote every promo
so like if you don't believe in me great
like have the guy has a guy like west
side gun or uh it tried to give you any
pointers because he's a huge i don't
know i think anybody [ __ ] listens to
anybody else's music bro like do do do
anything i mean you're in here
all day i'm assuming i'm just assuming
no other rappers anymore yeah i'm
assuming that you know there's there's
like that built-in like
the smoke dizzs and the water this is on
my track virgil
me and virgil me and smoke this did a
track called virgil mm-hmm
uh and the song's hot and smoke heard it
and he asked me to get on it oh wow
so like that's what i mean man i'm a
different sound than that first album
that album ain't what i bring to the
table you know what i mean like i'm i'm
you're still getting better don't put me
in the box bro like [ __ ] unless it's
a casket match is it very hard to
break the stigma when people first just
kind of like i'm still trying to break
it now and it's going to be a while but
i ain't i ain't scared like yo if you
don't listen to my music i bet you
[ __ ] will you that's how it got
that's how it goes i don't
look it man i'm fighting an uphill
battle i was looked at as a pro wrestler
people only see me as enzo amore too
they don't like
i could have went and played you know a
gothic guy that [ __ ] stabbed you you
know what i mean like whatever like that
that's who you play on yeah this is your
character so like yeah there's an ounce
of ounce enzo and eric you know what i
mean or a couple ounces maybe a couple
[ __ ] you know short of a [ __ ] quad
but
i'm in there